Okay, welcome to the very last class,
the grand finale. Today we do the
American Empire. July 1944, this is the
Brenon Woods Hotel in New Hampshire. 40
nations get together and they discuss
what the post-war peace will look like.
Um, everyone knows that Nazi Germany
will eventually be defeated as well as
Japan. So, the question now is how does
the world build peace? um and prosperity
after such a devastating uh war. And the
Americans propose the bread and wood
system. The idea is this. The idea is to
facilitate global trade. The American
currency will become the reserve
currency of the world. Meaning that
everyone can use it to trade. Um now the
term we use for this is exorbitant
privilege. This is like the power of God
because you're basically turning taking
paper and turning into gold, right?
That's the power of God. So, how can we
ensure the Americans won't abuse this
power? And the answer is the Americans
agree to create a global financial
network as well as peg
the currency to gold, which means that
the USD is a contract. Um, and at any
point you can choose to exchange US
dollars for gold. And so what America
does is it transports all the gold from
London to Fort Knox and that becomes the
basis for the new uh global financial
system that we still have today and um
it is incredibly successful.
This is the bank of international
settlements in Basel, Switzerland. It is
the bank of banks. It is a central bank
of central banks and the idea here is um
you need to create a system for risk man
for risk mitigation. So for example if
maybe um a country goes bankrupt the
other countries need to come in and uh
rescue that country's economy. Okay. And
so this bank is some of you never heard
of but it's one of the most powerful
institutions in the world because it
facilitates the entire global financial
economy.
Brenon Woods also created something
called the World Bank um which is based
in Washington DC and what it does is
that um it gives out loans to third
world nations like China.
The IMF the international monetary fund
coordinates global financial policy.
Okay. So um the the the bank of
international settlements, the world
bank, the IMF among other organizations
now becomes the global financial system
and underpinning all of this is the US
dollar as the global reserve currency.
Okay. So um where did the system come
from? Well, comes from 1688. Remember
this is the year that William of Orange
of the Netherlands he goes to England
and launches something called the
Glorious Revolution and he takes a
throne from James II. When he goes to
England he also brings with him Dutch
wealth right because the Netherlands is
now the most prosperous nation in the
world because of global trade. They have
something called the Dutch um West
Indies company that has monopolized the
spice trade in um um East Asia. So it's
the Dutch East East East East East
Indies Company and so it's extremely
wealth. Now as we discussed previously
the Dutch are Calvinists. So they that
so they believe that there's a religious
obligation for them to get wealthy.
Wealth will guarantee their entry into
heaven. But for that to happen, they
need to ensure their wealth is
protected, right? And at this point in
history, the the Netherlands is at is
being conquered or at war with France,
with uh Spain, with with a host of of
enemies. So, it's not the money isn't
safe in uh the Netherlands. So, it's
being transferred over to England
because England has a navy that is the
most powerful in the world. It's also an
island, so it's pretty hard to invade.
1694, this wealth becomes the basis of
the Bank of England, which is considered
the second um oldest central bank in the
world, but it's really the first central
bank in the world. The reason why is
um this bank it's a private bank but
it's guaranteed by parliament which
means that the nation state of England
promises to always pay back the
investors in this bank. So why does this
happen? It happens because it will
resolve a huge issue throughout human
history. If you're a king, you need
financing to go to war. You often need
to pay for missionaries.
um to get this money you need to
basically borrow from your wealthiest
citizens. The problem with this is as
king you may not want to pay back that
money after the war or you could get
killed in the war. Okay? So there's
always tremendous risk when you lend
money to the king. The Bank of England
solves this problem because you're not
lending money to the king, you're
lending money to England and the people
will always have to pay you back. All
right? So maybe they won't pay you back
today, but they'll have to pay you back
sooner or later. Okay? Because it's
guaranteed by parliament. And this
system is extremely successful. In fact,
this system is what allows England to
defeat Napoleon
um in a no plank wars. Okay. In 1815,
Napoleon is finally defeated. Um so as
we discussed previously, Napoleon, he is
a military genius and he conquers most
of Europe and he defeats England many
many times. But because of the bank of
England, Napoleon, the English have
infinite financing. So the British are
always financing wars against Napoleon
until he is finally defeated. And this
establishes the British Empire. Okay. So
after the defeat of Napoleon and France,
uh Britain becomes the global hedgeimon.
And the Bank of England now becomes an
imperial bank. And the power of this is
um before when you go when you go and
conquer um a um a country or a nation,
you're always afraid of rebellion,
right? You're always afraid of local
elite getting getting together and
overthrowing you. But the Bank of
England solves this problem. Why? It
solves this problem because now the
local elite can take their corrupt
earnings and put it in the Bank of
England. All right? So now the elite
have an incentive to work with the
British to maintain their empire and
that's how Britain was able to build the
world's first truly global empire and
able to maintain such harmony and
stability with empire for such a long
time. Okay. The secret was international
finance as embodied by the bank of
England. Okay. So let's summarize the
history of central banking. Okay. It's
complicated but we need to understand
this history if we understand today's
world. First important idea is that
those coalists um they have a religious
obsession with storing wealth. Okay,
remember we discussed this right? The
Protestant religion demands that you get
rich.
The parliament of England guarantees
this wealth does given England infinite
financing for wars. This is important
because if parliament is willing to
guarantee financing
um not only can it use all this wealth
stored in the bank of England but it can
also generate new wealth from investors
overseas as well. Okay. Third idea this
financing infinite financing allows
Britain to defeat Napoleonia.
Fourth, the Bank of England stores
wealth of corrupt local elites allowing
for stability and and harmony within the
within the empire. Now this is
important. What will happen next is
America will emulate this model and
create something called the Federal
Reserve in the year 1914. So the idea of
the Federal Reserve is if all these
provincial banks around America, they
get together and decide uh that we as
private banks will convince the
government, the Congress to give us a
power to print money. How do you print
money? You issue loans. Okay? when you
issue loans, you're basically putting
money into the system. Okay. So, um in
1914, developed the Federal Reserve
system and after World War uh two,
America is now able to export this
Federal Reserve system all around the
world by creating independent central
banks in each nation and having these
central banks work together to create
more wealth for their investors. So,
this is something really important you
have to understand. Nation states
compete against each other. But
independent central states, all these
nation states work together because that
way it's easier for them to generate
wealth for their investors. Okay? To
grow capital, private central banks
coordinate rather than compete. There
are parasites that feed off the nation
state. Okay? So this is a really
important idea that no one understands.
The nation state is responsible for
protecting this wealth and the central
banks can use the resources of the
nation state to feed its capital growth.
Okay. And this is the modern financial
system that we have today. The central
banks basically rule the world.
All right.
Okay. So, um this is Carol Quickley and
he wrote a book called Tragedy and Hope,
which I highly recommend. He was a
Georgetown professor. He was um Bill
Clinton's favorite professor at
Georgetown. And um in his book, he
explains how this financial system
works. Okay, so let's read it very
carefully. And this is he's talking
about the 1920s after World War I. The
powers of financial capitalism had
another far-reaching aim. nothing less
than to create a world system of
financial control in private hands able
to dominate the political system of each
country and the economy of the world as
a whole. This system was to be
controlled in a feudalist fashion by the
central banks of the world acting in
concert by secret agreements arrived at
in frequent private meetings and
conferences. The apex of the system was
to be the bank of for international
settlements in Bassau, Switzerland. a
private bank owned and controlled by the
world's central banks which were
themselves private corporations. Each
central bank in the hands of men like
Montigue Norman of the Bank of England,
Benjamin Strong of the New York Federal
Reserve, Charles Riss of the Bank of
France, and Hel of the Ratsburg sought
to dominate its government by its
ability to control treasury loans to
manipulate foreign exchanges to
influence the level of economic activity
in the country and to influence
cooperative politicians by subsequent
economic rewards in the business world.
Okay. So in today's world, it's
essential banks act in concert that
dictate financial, economic and
political policy all around the world.
All right. So how can we understand um
central banks? Well, the main function
of central banks is to uh control the
money supply. Okay. So money is just a
concept. It's an idea. It's something
that we just made up. And the way the
central bank controls money is by
controlling its scarcity which creates
the illusion that it's valuable. Okay.
Also, you're forced to use money to buy
things as well as pay taxes, take out
loans. All right. Um, and they control
the interest rate, which is the cost of
borrowing money. So, another way of
saying this is one mechanism the central
bank has to control the economy is by
lowering or by lowering or increasing
interest rates. If it lowers interest
rate, it's just easier, cheaper to
borrow money, right? So you can go buy a
house or buy a car. They increase the um
interest rate. It's more expensive. So
people spend less money. So through that
mechanism, they're able to control the
supply of money in the system. All
right. All right. So how can we
understand what central bankers are?
Well, I'll give you three possible
metaphors, okay? And I think these are
all legitimate. Central bankers are the
ultimate priest. They must control the
flow of money to maintain the illusion
that money is God. In this way, they are
the new Catholic Church. Okay? Remember
the Catholic Church in medieval Europe
was the dominant power. It was uh beyond
nations. Um it was it represented God on
earth. Well, that's what central bankers
are today. But also,
you can think of central bankers as the
game masters. They must control the flow
of money to motivate people to play the
game. As we discussed when we discussed
the Americans today, we live not in a
civil civilization but in a game where
we're all individual players trying to
make as much money as possible. Now
central bankers are the ones who control
the rules of this game.
Last metaphor is central bankers are
drug pushers to expand their dominance.
They offer easy money and once a country
is addicted or bankrupt, they hijack the
financial system which means to
privatize or make independent the
central bank. Okay. So, how do central
bankers work? Well, let's let let's
let's let's do an experiment, okay?
Let's let's use a thought experiment.
Let's just say I'm a central bank and
you and I'm trying to get you to become
addicted to my power, right? So, what I
do is this. I say to you, "Hey, here's
$10,000." And you're like, "Okay, and
what do you want for $10,000?" I'm like,
"Nothing. Just go enjoy yourself." So,
so you take that $10,000 and you go go
on vacation to Hawaii.
You live in a fivestar hotel. You're
really happy. You come back and he says,
"That was great. Can I get more money?"
And I'm like, "Here, here's a million
dollars. Go and enjoy yourself." And
you're like, "What do you want for it?"
I'm like, "Nothing. Just go enjoy
yourself." So, you go. But this time,
you're smarter. You're like, "No, no,
no, no. This money is limited. I need to
go invest it if I want to generate more
money. Okay? Otherwise, I have I have to
go back to the bank and get more money."
So, you start doing you start um opening
businesses. You invest in restaurants
and ski resorts. Who knows? Okay. But
you you have all these investments. The
problem is you really don't know what
you're doing. And you make these bad
investments. And eventually what you
recognize is you're in debt now. You had
a million dollars, but now you owe $10
million. So, you come back to the bank
and you say, "Listen, I need $10
million." I'm like, "Fine, but now you
have to give me your soul."
And you're like, "You're just stuck."
Okay, that's how central banks work. I
like I I know this sounds terrible, but
that's really how they work in the
world. All right, so I'll give you
examples. All right, so what central
banks do is they have the power of God.
They're alchemists basically because
they can take paper uh which we know is
worthless and turn it into gold which is
what everyone wants.
Um now something to remember and this is
really important is that throughout
history whenever there's a major power
there's always a rising power that
challenges it. So in our world today
there's no nation state that can
challenge the power of central banks but
there are these technology companies
that are arising that are trying to
displace them from godhood. Okay. So um
Bitcoin is something they've invented.
It is the American military's failsafe
system in case the American government
defaults on the debt and the US dollar
loses its reserve currency status. So,
Bitcoin is being controlled by the
American military along with certain
technology companies and they're trying
to displace the USD. All right. So, so
there's a conflict going on here. All
right. Also, artificial intelligence
will be used to create the illusion of
God, right? Why is there so much
investment interest in artificial
intelligence? Because even though it
doesn't really work that well, it can
trick people into believing it is God,
that it is omniscient, that it is always
right, that is the ultimate authority.
Last example,
sorry, last example is social media,
video games, and porn are the drug of
the 21st century. Okay, so in other
words, these technology companies,
they're really in the process of
creating a matrix in which we just live
in a simulation and we're all slaves to
the simulation. Okay. So um um this is
something that we have to think about
how the central banks are in power but
there's always powers that are arising
and which will challenge the power of
the central banks. Okay. So how do we
get this system? Um go back to year 1950
1960. The world divided into two right?
It's divided between the capitalist west
and the communist east. Now this is
ultimately a war of ideology. It's
really a question of which system
capitalism or communism it's better for
humanity. Well well we don't know the
answer to that that question but we do
know the elite prefer capitalism because
capitalism gives them more power gives
them more wealth. So the elites both in
China and the Soviet Union they
basically give up. Okay. Okay. In 1991,
the Soviet Union basically
unconditionally surrenders and this
creates the complete dominance of the
American system, the PAX Americana.
Um, so once America has domination, it
now can spread its system throughout the
world. This is Carl Pauper and he wrote
a book called the open society and in it
he questions
um grand ideologies because he believes
that it's these grand ideologies like
communism and fascism that have
destroyed the world and which have led
to World War II. He hates Plato, he
hates Marx, he hates Hegel. He thinks
these are the three totitarian
philosophers in human history. And so
what he proposes is that the height of
civilization is the Anglo-American
civilization. Okay? The Germans and the
Russians are bad because they are
racist, because they are nationalistic,
because they are grand in their vision.
They're always trying to transform
humans to shapes and um things that hum
that that that are anti-human. But the
Americans and the British, they are
practical. They are utitarian. they are
they believe in evolution. Okay. And he
and that's why call and so Carl proper
believes the Anglo-American civilization
is really the height of human
civilization.
But there's actually another way to
understand the Pax Americana. And so the
idea is from World War II we we transfer
to Pax Americana and there are major
differences, right? So World War II was
about the nation state. That was the
main constituent body of World War II.
In the fact of Americana, what matters
is the international rulesbased order
which includes central banks but also
includes United Nations, right? Um World
War II is about mercantalism.
Mechanalism is that you only trade
within your sovereignty. Okay? You only
trade with your colonies. But Pax
American argues for global free trade.
Global free trade will lead to
prosperity in the world. World War II
argues for unit of will and Paxame
argues for consumerism. Okay, the unit
of will is the idea that we must be a
whole that the constituent parts
together are less than the whole. Okay,
consumerism is just individuals should
just go and spend money and enjoy the
life and don't worry about big problems
like the nation state um end of history
these ideas. All right. In other words,
what's happened in our world is the
world's gone from one that focus on
civilization to a game. In a in a
civilization, people are citizens who f
who sacrifice themselves in order to
obtain glory. Okay? So, think of
Achilles, right? Achilles went to Troy
because he was a competition among the
his his other Greeks to uh seek eternal
glory. Okay. But in a game, we're all
individual players who are trying to
make as much money as possible. Now, in
theory, you're taught that, okay, the
best way to do that is to work hard, be
smart, be talented, create something
innovative, right? But in reality, the
best way to make money is by cheating.
Okay, what what what is cheating? We
cheating is basically creating monopoly
and then you're forced and everyone's
just forced to uh pay as much as you
want. Okay. So, John Rockerfeller, um
Bill Gates, these were all monopolists
and and they were the wealthiest people
in human history. Okay.
All right. So, um after
uh World War II, America is the
only major industrial nation left
standing. And America uses opportunity
to rebuild both its economy as well as
the global economy. And it does so by um
trans transferring its wartime economy
into a peace time economy. Okay? In a
wartime economy, you're m manufacturing
goods at mass, right? When a peace time
economy, you're also doing that. The
problem though is now that you have
peace, who's going to buy these
products? So what America did was it
basically said to Europe, we'll make
these products, these manufactured
goods, these cars, and you will buy
them. Europe is like we have no money.
And America's like, "Don't worry about
it. We'll lend you the money." Okay? And
so, uh, this worked out really well for
America. If you were a white high school
graduate
male in America 1950s and 60s,7s, you
had the best life. You lived better than
the nobility of Rome. Okay, this is just
a guy. He could be a salesperson. He
could be a clerk. He could be a factory
worker. But he had a car. In fact, he
probably had two cars. He had his own
house. His wife didn't have to work. And
he could send his three kids to college.
Also, they could take one or two
vacations a year to Europe. It was
really the best life. And that's what
the P american Americana created. Okay?
Prosperity and peace for the American
middle class. But the problem is that
over time, the Germans start to catch
up. The Germans uh were destroyed in
World War II. So they were incentivized
to work together to work hard to rebuild
their uh civilization and German
manufacturing became famous throughout
the world as did Japanese manufacturing.
Okay. So now what's happening is because
of the security of German and Japanese
manufactured goods, America was
transitioning transitioning from a
creditor nation where everyone owed it
money to a debtor nation where its
consumers were buying things that they
couldn't really afford from overseas.
Okay. And again,
America did do so because America had
the US dollar as a reserve currency.
Um 1961, Dwight Eisenhower is retiring
from the presidency and he says to the
American people, um I know we are at war
with the Soviet Union. It's a cold war,
but we don't have any real enemies. Our
enemies are all internal. There is
currently in place something called the
military-industrial complex. They employ
millions of people. They manufacture
weapons and are intent on war. They are
our true enemy. If we allow the
military-industrial complex to hijack
the American political system, then
we'll be c then we'll be constantly
fighting these useless wars that will
back up our nation. Be aware. This is
our greatest threat to our nation in our
history. Okay. This is his farewell
address. The potential for the
disastrous rise of misplaced powers
exists and will persist. We must never
let the weight of this combination
endanger our liberties or democratic
processes. Okay, he's talking about the
military-industrial complex and it
proved present and prophetic because
after he retire after he retired,
America will start engaging in wars
around the world that it could neither
afford nor could it fight properly and
it bankrupted America. Most famous
example is the Vietnam war. Okay. uh
where America lost about 50,000 soldiers
and killed millions and millions of
Vietnamese civilians. It was a
pointless, brutal war that almost
bankrupted America and it almost caused
a civil war in America, right?
Um at this time, America was also
competing in with the Soviet Union in
the space race, right? So in 1969,
America sent um a man to the moon. And
this is a real picture. Okay? Now, some
of you might be like, some of you who
might be conspiracy theorists, okay? Not
me, but some of you might be conspiracy
theorists say, "Wait a minute here. Why
is the lighting perfect on the moon?"
Right? And why are there no stars in
this in space? And why is this flag uh
floating around? Okay, conspiracy
theorists would would ask these
questions. I don't ask these questions
because I'm not a conspiracy theorist.
Just just so we're completely sure.
Okay. Also at this time, Lynen B.
Johnson announced the Great Society,
which was this fantastic social program
to ensure that each and every American
had an opportunity at the American
dream. Okay? So, you had um um free
healthcare for the elderly. You had
programs like Head Start. It was
fantastic, but it's also really really
expensive. So if you are um a nation
like France, you're like, you know what,
America is sending people to the moon.
Um it's fighting all these pointless
wars and it's um um building all these
great social programs for its
population. Does America have the money
to do this? In other words, is it
possible that the US currency, the US
dollar, is no longer able to repay its
obligations? That's why France under
Charles de Gaul sent warships to America
in the mid60s to repatriate its gold.
it's afraid that America will uh go
bankrupt and this proved very very wise
and at this and when after France did
this there's now this fear among
Americans that every nation will do this
and then every nation did this America
will go bankrupt right that's why in the
year 1971 Richard Nixon announces the US
dollar will no longer be tied to gold
which means that you can't use US
dollars to buy gold anymore. Which means
what? Which means the US dollar is based
on nothing. The value of the US dollar
is now based primar primarily on
people's faith in its value. Okay.
So this leads to a lot of problems like
inflation and oil shock. So to solve
this problem in 1977 Nixon has agreement
with Saudi Arabia. Basically the
agreement is that from now on Saudi
Arabia which is the world's largest oil
exporter will only take payments in US
dollars and whatever savings that sa has
will be invested in US treasuries. Okay.
So this is what we call the petrol
dollar
and the idea here is now the value of
the US dollar is tied to the value of
oil. Okay, you can always exchange US
dollars for oil. But then Nixon did
something that was all that was
extremely clever. He went to China.
Okay, so for the longest time, China and
United States were in a cold war.
Americans basically isolated China. So
1972, Nixon visited Maong.
Why? The answer is very simple. Because
he needed more consumers to buy US
dollars. Does that make sense? He needed
people to want US dollars. He needed to
create a US dollar addiction. And to do
this, what did America do? America gave
China everything. America started to
ship its factories overseas to China.
America gave all its expertise and
technology to China. America started to
to educate the Chinese elite. And what's
really important is American defense
companies started to give military
secret technology to China. Okay. Now I
know that in United States people
believe that China stole this
technology. China didn't have to steal
this technology because America gave it
to China for free. Okay. Why would why
would America do this? To create
dependence on America. Because once a
dependence is created then Chinese will
want US dollars. Okay. The intention has
always been to create a market for US
dollars in order to prop up the uh US
currency. Okay? Does that make sense? So
Saudi Arabia uh gave its oil to United
States and China gave its labor okay its
most precious commodity to the United
States in exchange for US dollars.
All right. So why is this important?
Let's look at the case of Japan. The
year is 1985. Okay? And this is called
the Plaza Court. The Plaza court was
between the central bankers um and the
finance ministries of different nations,
but primary between United States and
Japan. Japan at this point was an export
powerhouse. It was the second largest
economy in the world. Um high savings
rate. Uh people really didn't want to
buy American goods. But but Americans
love Japanese goods. Okay? Right? So was
creating this trade imbalance and Japan
was growing and becoming an economic
powerhouse. So America said to Japan,
listen,
you guys need to restructure your
economy because your consumers aren't
spending any money. This creates trade
imbalance and ultimately this will lead
to structural problems in Japan. So what
we're going to do is we will revalue
the Japanese currency. We will
appreciate it with we will appreciate it
against the US dollar. Okay? So, as
Japanese um consumers, you're able to
buy more from the United States. Now,
Japanese uh economists thought this was
a terrible idea, but because America has
military bases in Japan, Japan didn't
really have a choice in the matter,
right? And so, this created
um the Japanese
uh explosion of wealth. Okay. So they
were by Rockefeller um plaza in New York
City and this created uh affair of Japan
in uh in the United States. So to show
you to demonstrate you to you how
ridiculous situation was in the year
1990 uh in Kyoto the imperial grounds
okay I'm not talking about the city of
Kyoto I'm talking about the imperial
grounds in Kyoto. Okay that land by
itself was worth more than Canada as a
country. You could you could sell the
imperial grounds of Ko and go buy Canada
for yourself. Okay, that's how
ridiculous the situation was in Japan.
Because of the appreciation of the yen,
cheap money flooded into the nation of
Japan and so people were speculating on
real estate and the stock market. Okay,
which led to ultimately economic
collapse in Japan. So as you can see um
from the 60s up until about the 90s
Japanese growth was pretty strong but
after the plastic accord you saw a steep
drop. Okay the plastic cords by
appreciating the yen by giving Japanese
easy money it destroyed the Japanese
economy.
All right so remember this. If you want
to nuke an economy and a nation you
really want to destroy an economy in a
nation give them easy money. All right.
If I want to destroy you as a person,
I'm gonna give you a million dollars
because you're gonna take that million
dollars and do stupid things with it.
Okay.
Can you clarify a bit of easy money? Oh,
okay. Yeah. Um, what does easy money
mean? Easy money just means that you
think it's free. You don't have to you
have to work for it. You don't have to
um earn it. Okay? And the idea of easy
money is central banks have the power to
print money. So, if you come to me, I'm
a bank. I can actually just give you a
million dollars and you take it. That's
easy money, right? Okay, that that's the
idea. Okay, so you don't understand
this. It's a hard concept to understand,
but banks have that power. They can just
put money out of nothing. Okay, and this
what I call easy money. And what this
leads to is disaster. Okay, so let's go
over the list of how easy money destroys
nations. First is that it turns
manufacturers into financial
speculators. The reason why is maybe
you're a car company, okay? Right? And
before you make you you're making good
money uh making cars and selling to the
Americans. But if the economy is is
blowing up, the stock market is
increasing, the real estate market is
increasing, you're actually better off
taking all your savings, your
investments, and putting into the stock
market, right? Because you you have
better returns. And as a corporation,
you have to guarantee better returns for
your investors. Okay? It makes people
lazy, selfish, and greedy. That's that's
easy to understand, right? If someone
just gave you a million dollars, you
would not want to work or study ever
again in your life. um you create too
much debt too quickly, you create
financial bubbles, corruption between uh
the politicians and the financial elite.
You create massive inequality, right?
Because it's usually the wealthy who
most benefit from this wealth
generation. Uh you will increase
unemployment and bankruptcies. And the
last thing, this is really important, is
because all all this surge in um um in
prices, you price up young people and
you destroy the nation's future. You
look at the birth rate in Japan, it's
about one. Okay? And the reason why is
Japanese young people do not see a
future for themselves. Houses are too
expensive. The um um jobs don't pay that
well. Okay. Um any questions before I
continue?
Is this fair? Okay. All right. Let's
continue. But it's not just Japan. It's
also the 1997 Asian financial crisis.
remember uh this is when South Korea,
Thailand, Indonesia
um their currencies were under attack
and because their currencies were under
attack um they became devalued. The
problem with this is um they before this
Thailand, Indonesia and South Korea had
access to easy money provided by central
banks and so so they could afford to buy
things overseas in investments overseas.
They could uh but once the value was was
de once the currency was devalued
they now went bankrupt. Okay? And as a
result the national moni monetary fund
was able to step in and prioritize the
central banks.
So that's a playbook. All right, 1989 is
important because that's when the Berlin
wall fell and the Soviet Union and
communism came to an end. Now it's a PAX
Americana. Okay, and in the Pax
Americana the system is America would
ship its manufacturing overseas.
Remember manufacturing was a source of
middle class wealth generation. Now it's
shipping all all its manufacturing
overseas to focus on financialization.
All right. So the idea is that Wall
Street would take all its money, all its
wealth being generated overseas and then
take it back to America and use it to um
invest in America to basically engage in
financial games. Okay, does that make
sense? So in other words, before America
was manufacturing things like cars and
and washing machines. Now America is a
scambling. Okay, the entire economy is
based on gambling anymore. And this will
lead to something called the 2008 great
financial crisis where the global
economy collapses basically
um 2001 911
um the world trade center right uh the
terrorist attacks again I'm not
conspiracy theorist so I'm not going to
go into the conspiracies behind this but
it lead it alleged something called a
war on terror where America for no
particular reason went to Iraq Syria
Libya and destroyed destroyed these
countries. Now, if you're a conspiracy
theorist, you would say, well, they
destroyed these countries because these
countries didn't have central banks,
right? So, that's what some people say.
I would not say that. I'm not conspiracy
theorist. 2008 is the great financial
crisis. Why did it happen? It happened
because America had become a gambling
economy. And so, it had to take money
and invest it. The problem though is
there's too much money flowing into
America and there's not enough good
investments. So what Wall Street did was
it started to invest in really bad
investments. It was encouraging people
with no money to go and buy out buy like
five houses. Okay? And eventually they
would have to default and when they
default it would create a cascading
effect where the entire global economy
would collapse and that's what the
what's what was the 2008 great financial
crisis. To solve this problem, what
America did was print money. Okay, look
at this guys. Up until the year 1980,
America had about a trillion dollars in
debt. Okay, America was signed in 1776.
By the year 1980, about 20 years later,
it had a trillion dollars in debt.
Today, it has now $37 trillion in debt.
Okay, this is all money printing.
Starting about 2008, boom, you you see
the steep curve going all the way up.
All right.
Um, the economy in America right now is
really screwed up. The reason why is the
stock market is is worth twice as much
as the real economy. Okay, that makes no
sense at all. The total value of the US
economy is half of that of the stock
market. Okay. So, this shows you that
right now America is living in a
fantasy. It's a makebelieve economy.
Um
um the other problem is this massive
wealth inequality. Okay. So, as you can
see um the wealth wealthy people are
pretty wealthy but by by 2000 uh but but
but by 1980 the time of Reagan it shoots
all the way up. Okay. Okay, so you have
this massive wealth inequality being um
um created in the United States. Th this
also shows you how wealthy the top 0001%
are relative to everyone else. Okay. So
the main beneficiaries of all these
reforms of this financation has been the
ultra wealthy in America.
Um, at the same time, if you're an
average American, all you've seen is
your debt go up. Okay? Your debt has
gone way up. So, you can make the
argument that this system is designed to
exploit the middle class by forcing into
debt so as to to enrich the wealthy's
investments. Okay, that's the American
system. And in fact, you can argue the
global system. So 2008 the global
economy collapses. So
what happens okay and I believe this is
what happened. I don't think this is
conspiracy theory. The central banks
basically encouraged the Chinese central
bank to start printing money right and
this is important because when you start
printing money and you invest in real
estate you need resources. You need to
buy resources from Australia from
Brazil. And this is what saves the
global economy. And this all looks very
impressive guys. Like I know when you go
outside, you see all these big buildings
and um fancy
um railways, it's all very impressive.
But remember, okay, this is really
important. Behind the veneer of this
prosperity are three things. Massive
debt, right? Because this money is being
printed. So someone has to pay this off.
You guys, not not the current people,
but you guys or your grandchildren or
your great-grandchildren. Okay? But
someone has to pay off this debt. That's
number one. Number two is this has
created massive inequality
in China,
right? So the rich are filthy rich and
the poor aren't that much better off.
The third problem that's really
important is it's created a lot of
political corruption. All right, so
behind all this veneer are corruption,
inequality, and debt.
And this is what
Okay, so a really important lesson for
you guys to understand the Chinese
relationship with America is this.
There's this very famous quote by
Charles Bier who said, "The greatest
trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he didn't exist."
Okay? Well, I'm I'm going I'm going to
paraphrase him, okay? And and this is
what I think is the relationship between
America and China. The greatest trick
America played was convincing China it
could be rich. All right? This is no
different from 1985 the plaster cords
when America basically encouraged the
Japanese to increase the value of their
yen which led to economic collapse.
Well, but when when the Americans
encouraged the Chinese to print money in
about 2008 and about um 2015, it
basically created conditions for China's
economic collapse. Okay.
All right. This is what led to the rise
of this man, our dear fearless leader.
Okay. Um, I believe his intentions are
good. I think he wants to save China
from this global financial capitalist
system. He needs to maintain China's
independence and sovereignty and he's
fighting very hard to
um save the Chinese nation. Okay, that's
what I believe. Um, and
so you can make the argument that what's
happening today in China is no different
from the open wars. Remember
Britain um created an opium epidemic in
China in order to enslave the Chinese
economy to the global financial system.
Right? That's that was the opium wars.
Well, the same is happening today where
the Americans have basically created a
Chinese dependency on US dollars, right?
What is the Chinese dream? The Chinese
dream is work hard, get into a good
school,
get rich,
move your money and your children to
United States. That's a Chinese dream.
All right. And if that's a dream, then
eventually the civilization won't last
very long. Am I wrong?
Is that not Is that not the Chinese
dream? All right. All right. So now you
have the COVID uh crisis where China's
locked down for three years.
Now I'm not conspiracy theorists, okay?
But you can make the argument that some
of this was intentional in order to
implode the Chinese economy. Why?
Because Chinese economy had become a
system of transferring wealth from China
to United States. So by imploding the
economy, you're stopping this drainage.
Okay.
All right. This also led to the rise of
this man Vladimir Putin who is very much
like Joseph Stalin. He understands the
grand picture. He understands strategy,
grand strategy. He understands that now
it's time to strike. Why? Because
America has created this crazy
fantastical system, right? Where there's
a hierarchy of prices. In the American
system, the tax americana
man resources are the least valuable.
Okay? The basis of the resources, right?
Which is what Russia has a lot of. Up
next in this pyramid is manufacturing
which is what China does. Then up next
is knowledge economy. So professionals
and that's what Europe and America does
really well. Okay. And at the very top
of this pyramid are the financeers
finance and that's what Wall Street
dominates. Okay. So this is the pyramid
of the world that we live in. What Putin
said is this. What Putin said is you
know what if I can control the world's
resources the oil the food then I can
invert this pyramid so that resource at
the top and that's why you uh Russia
invaded Ukraine because if Russia were
able to dominate Ukraine
Russia and Ukraine together would
control onethird
onethird of the world's carbohydrates
without Russian food Africa and the
ities would both starve to death. Okay?
And so that is the rationale for Putin's
invasion of Ukraine. He's a genius. He
understands there's fundamental weakness
in the American system. Okay? If you're
able to control the resources, you are
able to strangle this financial system.
Okay? So by invading Ukraine, Putin
shows that America is a paper tiger.
faith in the USD rests on the aura of
the American military's inability and
invincibility. This now forces the
Americans to invade Iran. Okay, does
that make sense to you guys? The logic
here is very simple.
Why does Saudi Arabia buy US dollars
even though they know it's not it's not
worth anything? Why what does Japan buy
US dollars? What does Germany? The
answer is they're afraid that if they
don't buy US dollars, America will come
invade them. Okay? They have no choice
in the matter. But now that Putin has
showed that actually you know what the
American military is not as strong as
you think it is. The American military
now has no choice but to prove it is as
strong as people believe. It needs to
restore faith in this in the military in
order to restore faith in the US dollar.
Okay, does that make sense?
[Music]
That's why
the American military has no choice in
the matter but to invade Iran. Okay,
why? because if they're able to invade
Iran, they're able to control the entire
flow of Middle East oil. Also, they're
able to control the active trade
throughout the world. Okay, Iran is
really the center of the world in terms
of global trade. So, these two factors
mean that America needs to eventually
invade Iran.
All right? Once it invades Iran, it
creates a huge problem for China and
Japan and South Korea. Why? Because
guess what? These three nations gets
most of this oil from the Middle East,
right? Japan imports roughly 89% of its
oil from the Middle East. And guess
what, guys?
Japan is the largest buyer of US
dollars. So if Japan ever says, you know
what, screw this. We're not buying US
dollars. The American economy goes
bankrupt. So when you invade Iran, you
control the oil supply. You control the
entire Japanese economy. You can charge
whatever price you want for oil.
All right, this explains the Israel
Palestine conflict because America just
can't go invade Iran for no reason. It
needs a pretext. The perfect pretext is
Israel comes to conflict with Iran. Iran
attacks Israel. United States must now
defend Israel because Israel is its
ally. Right? Does that make sense? So,
America needs a scapeold. That scapeold
is Israel. That explains why there's so
much conflict right now in the Middle
East.
Look at this map. Okay, this is Iran.
It's surrounded by American bases. You
have 14,000 troops in Afghanistan.
You've got like thousands more
over here. Okay, Iran. Iran is
surrounded. It seems to me that
America's been preparing to invade Iran
for the past 20 years. It's just looking
for the perfect opportunity.
All right. Problem though is that Iran
is not an adversary that America can
defeat. The reason why is the geography
of Iraq. Look at this. In 2003, America
went to Iraq and destroyed Iraq. Why?
Iraq's a desert. It's flat plains.
America has bombs. It has it has fighter
planes, right? It's pretty easy to
destroy a desert. But I Iran Iran is all
mountains. These fighter planes do no
good against mountains. You can't bomb a
mountain into submission. Okay? So if
America were to invade Iran, there's
very little ch very little chance that
um America would win this war. In fact,
it may be the end of the American
Empire.
And Putin has a plan. Okay, Putin is a
genius. He knows exactly what will
happen. So Putin is preparing for this
possible invasion
um of Iran. So this is a really
important picture.
Putin signed an agreement with Kim Jun.
The agreement is something called a
mutual defense pact which means that if
North Korea ever is ever attacked, Putin
would come to his aid.
All right. Now, why would Putin do this?
This is really strange. The answer is
this. The answer is if America attacks
Iran, he needs to throw America off
balance by creating a conflict somewhere
else. The best place to create a
conflict would be Southeast Asia. Right
now, you would think, wait a minute
here, Putin and China are best friends.
If America invades Iran, then China may
invade Taiwan.
But I already told you this, China is
dependent on the American economy. So I
do not believe this will happen. Okay?
And Putin is fairly certain this won't
happen either. That's why he's f he's
now best friends with Kim Jun because
Kim Jun if he were to menace South Korea
that would throw the American military
off balance because now there is war on
three fronts. Ukraine, South Korea and
Iran. Okay, that's a grand strategy of
Putin. This is his trump card.
Okay, does that make sense? All right.
Now, what I'm saying here is this. I'm
saying like I know there's a lot of
conflict now between China and America.
There's a trade war going on. Um but I
think this will pass. I think there'll
be a reproachment between China and
America because both economies are
dependent on each other.
Right? So I think this friendship
between Putin and China won't last very
long. Um there's also really a lot of
geopolitical reasons why this friendship
won't last very long, right? Because
China and Russia have a lot of
geopolitical conflicts, right? They
share a border. They're trying to vive
for influence in the um in Central Asia.
There's lots of reasons why in the long
term China and Russia eventually have to
break apart, which means that Putin now
sees his best friend could be Germany.
Okay, this is a this this I think are
going to be the two big geopolitical
surprises next five years. First of all,
America and China become best friends or
not best friends, but they'll have a
reproachment. And then Germany and
Russia will have a reproachment.
Okay.
All right. So, um, Donald Trump,
president of the United States, he wants
a third term. Okay. He's creating
everything he's doing right now is
because he wants to be king of the
United States. He wants a third term,
okay? for a variety of reasons. Okay, I
I won't go into many reasons, okay? But
he's that narcissistic. Um, he has he
has to solve a problem. His problem is
the national debt, right, is now $37
trillion. You can't pay this off. You
can never pay this off. But the theory
is the theory is like as long as you are
the greatest military in the world, as
long as you can go invade everyone, you
don't have to pay this off. You can you
can you can constantly increase this
debt. Okay, that's a theory.
Um, this explains the US China trade
war. Everything that we're seeing today
is because Donald Trump needs to come to
an agreement with China for a variety of
reasons. Okay. The first reason is uh
Trump wants to invade Iran and so he
needs to be on good terms with China.
Okay. Another reason is he needs people
to buy US dollars, right? And right now
there's a lot of financial repression in
China, meaning that you can't convert uh
Chinese currency into US currency.
uh American investors aren't allowed to
come to China and buy up um ch the
Chinese financial system. Trump wants
China to open up China Trump needs to
create more interdependency between
China and the United States. Okay? And
that's why
for Trump, Chinese citizens and students
in America is the ultimate leverage
point in negotiations. Ask yourself why
this is happening. Why is it that your
visas are being threatened? you want to
go to United States and spend a lot of
money to get American education. But
Trump is saying, "No, no, no. We get to
go to your visa." Why is this happening?
It's all part of of negotiation. Okay?
There's no way that America will shut
out Chinese students because America
needs that needs that money. Okay? Well,
without without Chinese spending money
in America, without Chinese wanting to
purchase US dollars, the American
company will collapse. So there's no way
that America will close its b its door
to Chinese students, but it needs China
open up its economy further more to
create more interdependency to save the
dollar. Okay.
All right. So where am I getting these
ideas? Like like am I just making this
stuff up? Um so in this class, what
you're taught is that
history tends to repeat itself. And by
studying history meticulously and
thoroughly, we can gain insight into the
future. So what I want to show you now
is there's a direct analogy between
what's happening today and what happened
in Greece um in about 400 BC. Okay, this
is um fusidities and he wrote a very
famous book called the history of the
pelipian war which is what we discussed
last semester. Now the pesian war is a
war between Athens and Sparta for
hedgemony. It um on the Greek mainland.
Okay. Um so in 480
Athens and Sparta were best friends.
They fought against Persia which was
invading the Greek mainland. And at the
battle of Salamus the Athenians
basically destroy the Persian navy and
the Persians were forced to retreat. But
there's always a threat that Persia over
here would would come back and invade uh
Athens and Sparta. Okay. As well
throughout the Aian Sea are Greek
islands and colonies that are afraid of
Persian hijgemony. So after the defeat
of the Persians, the Athenians got
together with these colonies and create
something called the Dian league. The
Dian league is like NATO. It's a
defensive line alliance. the Persians
attack then this alliance will um will
defend together against the the
Persians. Now the Athenians have the
best navy at this time and the other
islands are like you know we don't have
a navy but what we'll do is this we'll
give you our gold okay so to all these
um um islands they put all their wealth
on a place called Delos. This is why why
we have the Delian League name. Okay.
And this money is meant as a mutual
defense fund. You're not supposed to
touch it
until unless the Persians invade, in
which case you use this money to uh
defend against a person. Okay, that's
the idea. And this worked out well until
the Athenians stole the money, right? Uh
why? Because they want to create
something called the Parthonon. Okay,
which is one of the most beautiful
buildings in the world.
And within the building is the statue of
Athena. It's pure gold. Okay. So the
Athenian stole all this money from Delos
from their allies and they built this
Parthonon and the wealthy were able to
steal from the Parthonon in the
construction process. And so the
citizens of of of Athens became really
wealthy. It's easy money, right? And
remember, easy money destroys a society.
And so this is what led to the Pelvision
war because after Athens stole this
money, it didn't it it didn't apologize
to its allies. In fact, it forced its
allies to continue to pay tribute to
Athens. Athens became a mafia state.
Okay? A protection racket. If you don't
give us money, then we'll come invade
you. And so these allies started to
encourage Sparta to attack Athens and
that's what led to the P pelpian war.
Okay. So there are three major incidents
from the pelpian war that I want us to
focus on. The first incident is in 428
B.CE um a place called Metalin um an
island. They were a former um Athenian
ally who refused to pay tribute. So
Athenians invaded and conquer it. And
now the question is what do you do now?
How do you teach these guys a lesson?
How do you ensure this doesn't happen
again? So, um, one faction in Athens
said, "Let's kill all the men." Okay,
pretty simple, right? Let's kill all the
men and then we'll we'll, um, spread
fear among our allies and no one will
rebel against anymore. Um, so they have
have a debate and all say, "Let's kill
them all." So, they send a tri, a ship
to the island and to give the orders to
Athenian soldiers to kill everyone.
Well, not everyone, but the men and
enslave the women and the children.
Okay. But after after the debate, um the
Athenians started to talk amongst
themselves and a lot of them couldn't
sleep and they're like, "This is wrong.
We're Athenians. We are um we are a
democrat. We're a democracy. We fight
for freedom and liberty. We can't do
this to our allies." So the very next
morning, the Athenian citizens get
together and says, "We're going to have
another debate and we're going to
discuss what to do." And so they have
this huge debate. And they says, "No,
we're Athenians. we're virtuous. We will
not do this. So they send another tri
to catch up to the first tri. And
remember the first triim is way ahead,
right? They they they have a day's um um
um journey ahead. So the other triim,
they work their their asses off to catch
up to the first triim and at the very
last minute they catch up and they tell
the soldiers not to kill the men. Okay?
And so this is the constant between
democracy and empire. Right? Now let's
fast forward um to um 416. And now
another thing happens where the
Athenians are losing this war against
Sparta. It's cost them a lot of money.
Um they're forced to melt down the
statue of Athena, the goddess, and use
the gold to pay for this this war. Okay.
And so
um at and so their attitude changes and
now they're completely a mafia state.
They don't care about democracy, don't
care about virtue. All they want is for
the allies to pay tribute. Okay? So they
go invade an island called Melos. And
Melos is not part of this war. They're
not part of Sparta. They're not part of
Athens. They're just neutral. And then
the Athenians said, "We don't care. You
pay tribute to us." Okay? They're
basically like a mafia racket now. And
the and the the millennials say we we
we're neutral. Uh you have to respect
our neutrality. And the Athenian say in
response, right, as the world goes is
only in question between equals in power
while the strong do what they can and
the weak suffer what they must. All
right. So,
so 12 years later, the Athenian like
screw virtue, screw democracy, screw
liberty, just give us money.
All right. So remember this idea
Athenians wanted the tropics of empire
they also wanted to feel virtuous and
over time as a Athens became more poor
they were like screw virtue let's have
an empire and that's why
um in 415 alabades who who basically is
a trump of Athens at this time okay he
says to Athenian people hey guys we're
losing this war against Sparta but don't
worry let's go invade more territory
okay so they decide to go invade Sicily
which was very wealthy
The problem though is that Sicily is
pretty far away. Okay, remember this is
Athens. They're fighting this huge war
in the agency against the Spartans and
they're going to go and invade Sicily
for its money. Okay, and it's pretty far
away and it's not really well thought
out. They don't really think about how
to resupply the soldiers and eventually
their expedition gets wiped out um at
Syracuse. Okay. So, it's a disaster for
the Athenians and it turns the war in
favor of the Spartans.
Um, Athen is so bad that that everyone
gets together. The entire world gets
together to destroy Athens. The
Persians, remember the Persians were the
enemies of both Sparta and Athens,
right? The Persians start to finance the
Spartans and the Spartans eventually lay
siege to Athens and defeat the
Athenians. Okay, so why is this
important? Well, because history history
is going to repeat itself. Okay, there
there's going to be a lot of
similarities between the pelpian war and
and American empire today. First
similarity is NATO. Remember the
Athenians have the daily league and um
the Americans have NATO, okay? And NATO
is meant to be a def defensive alliance.
But if that's the case, then why is it
that the Nordstream pipeline got
destroyed? Remember the Nordstream
pipeline it sends cheap gas from Russia
to Germany. The German economy is use
cheap Russian resources primarily gas uh
manufacturing the best cars in the world
and sell to China. Okay. But because of
this war in Ukraine, um America not only
limited um basically embargoled uh
Russian gas to Germany which destroyed
the Russian economy, but some people
even say that the Americans destroy the
pipeline. Okay, so the Americans are
attacking their own allies.
Um Trump has said that Americans should
take over Greenland and Canada. Why?
because they're wealthy, they have lots
of resources, and also they don't have
really strong militaries, right? Trump,
he he's like a mafia godfather.
America's behaving like a mafia system
today.
Um, now what America is doing is it's
forcing Europe to rearm itself. So, so
this is Germany and Germany, Britain,
France, they've all announced this huge
military budgets. And so you're like,
"Okay, does this mean that we'll have
World War II?" Well, America doesn't
think like that. America isn't like, you
know, like, "Let's fight Russia."
America is like, "How can we um exploit
our allies further?" Right? And so you
can make the argument that this is not
really about fighting the Russians. It's
really about getting their allies,
France, Germany, and Britain to buy
expensive and crappy American weapons.
Remember the military industrial
complex, right? The entire point is not
to fight the Russians. The Russians are
just a pretext and excuse. The real
purpose is get the Europeans to buy
expensive American weapons. It's really
a shakeddown. Okay.
All right. So, um all around the world
there's protests about what's happening
in the Middle East, right?
Uh these are huge protests protesting
what's happening in Gaza today.
But ultimately it's not going to matter.
All right? Why? Because America is an
empire. It's a mafia state. It needs to
destroy Iran in order to maintain its
power. Okay? So Americans want the trap
of empire. They also want to feel
virtues. That's why there's conflict
right now. Over time, as America becomes
poorer and poorer and more and more
desperate, this virtue will go away and
the raw brutal power of America will
express itself throughout the world.
Um, and this will eventually lead to us
lead us to the final conflict, the war
between Iran and the United States. Um,
Iran has been has been preparing for a
long time. Okay? Ever since 1979,
um, America's been preparing for a long
time. This conflict is World War III. I
can't I cannot
um
overstate how brutal this conflict will
be. It will lead to fundamental changes
in the world. Our lives will never be
the same again. Everything that we've
known in the past is now gone forever,
and we have to prepare for a new future.
So,
um, I leave you with a message. Okay? I
know that this class has been
depressing. You've been with me for a
year now. It's been very depressing.
Okay? Because we've we've gone into the
heart of darkness of humanity. Um, and I
know that the world looks more and more
terrible.
But remember this, okay? And this is my
final message to you. Remember this. The
greatest minds of humanity which include
Homer, Dante, Emanuel Kant, they've all
told us this. They've all told us one
secret of the universe, one message,
which is this.
The imagination is the animating
animating force of the universe. Love is
a unifying force of the universe. Okay.
What this means is this, which what this
means is that in the darkest times when
all hope has been lost, when there's
only despair,
any of us, you, me, you, any one of us
can rise up, stand up, and be the light
to lead humanity forward. Okay? And
that's the task ahead of us if we are to
save humanity in this darkest of times.
Okay. So remember this. We all have the
capacity to imagine. We all have the
capacity to love. That's what makes us
human. In the worst times, we must
defend our own humanity.
Okay. So that is it. Thank you so much.